also did you get a guy with any april
fools [ __ ] yeah i did you got bodied
yeah i uh this is gonna sound like a
flex but it's not but uh my girl goes uh
there is a there's a um a hotel or like
a resort in aspen
and they said they just announced that
they're gonna have a wave pool coming
this summer so you can surf in aspen at
this hotel that's sick and i looked at
the post and i saw the people that are
gonna go surf there and kelly slater was
one of the people that was gonna go surf
there so i dm'd it to kelly slater and
i'm like i'm like dude are they really
building a [ __ ] wave pool at this
hotel and kelly slater had to let me
know that
i got
april fool's like a [ __ ] idiot wait
he he
yeah he's like dude i think you got an
april fools and i was like okay yeah
yeah they didn't build a weight pull in
the side of a [ __ ] mountain your
actual hero was like yeah you're an
idiot yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
wasted a dm on an api falls too huge
anything out of it huge nothing nothing
at all but besides looking like an idiot
it's only a girl to set you up though
yeah dumbass
you know
not shifty got me on the
on the it was like the northern lights
in new york did you see this no it was
like going down viral it was like yeah i
heard about this i believed it luckily i
went to new york
they're looking like a [ __ ] car it's
like you'll be able to see the northern
lights this year for the first time but
this week for the first time like 50
years the shift was like isn't that
crazy and i believed it up until like i
think an hour ago no yeah i was like
literally like a future oh i did get got
by
yeah
when he was like his new like uh he's
dressed like a wildling yeah
i was like and he was like this is my
new construction wear or whatever and i
believed it and i was like dude ben what
is this because it was kind of fire but
i was like i didn't i didn't think i got
got by april fools turned out i got by
all of it i just thought you know all
this is not the world that changed it
wait a minute um
i got
by a speed limit a walking speed limit
in new york and after i post that i was
like oh i hope this is true and then i
realized it was fake so then i started
finding all the fake posts and postings
so i'm like no i'm doing this on purpose
guys
that's smart yeah yeah that's smart
that's [ __ ] genius
um akash you never told us about your
drive for 11 hours
son
i'm gonna say this i drove through that
[ __ ] and i was like i would have voted
for trump too wait really yo it's just
hopeless dog it's 11 hours of
hopelessness no that's all you're
looking at is nothing toledo ohio the
brewery was out of bus it was like a
[ __ ] abandoned warehouse so you can't
even afford alcoholism yeah that [ __ ]
blew my [ __ ] mind the trailer park
like the trailers are run down i was
like this [ __ ] is hopeless dude how was
the sunday show we didn't have the
sunday lucky no i thought about this and
i i felt guilt i usually i've been
selling out a decent amount and i was
like yo 80 of the room is only full
there's no 100 and then i was like oh
there's probably like 50 unemployment so
i actually mathematically on my head it
was 130 sell out yeah you killed oh yeah
i really killed it hundred percent they
didn't even bother with the sunday show
i think i'm like pay for no [ __ ] no
you're lucky yeah i i mean that was the
worst i've ever done in my entire life
they told me did you ask them about it
no no they told me at the end of the
night they were like hey we love andrew
tell him to come back he doesn't seem to
want to
wait dad she said that yeah i had a hard
to tell her poor manager she didn't i
didn't see her all weekend because she
was making [ __ ] chicken tenders or
whatever because they don't have labor
in ohio and uh
she was like at the end of the night
she's like hey thanks we had a bunch of
new people come out great i said oh
andrew probably brought a lot of these
same people and she's like oh we love
andrew he just hasn't come back since
the last time
yeah it was a rough one man
oh that show
there's only two shows that i really
remember i'm like wow never get and
they're both in ohio well toledo and
toledo and then columbus i did a show in
columbus where i was getting absolutely
nothing from the audience so i just
brought the stool to the middle of the
stage
and i just stood on the stool
and delivered my jokes standing on the
stool
why why i don't know
i was like i got to make this fun for me
somehow you thought height was the issue
for yeah it
yeah no i was like this has just got to
be fun maybe if i balance i'll have more
fun in it and yeah it was both ohio ohio
could be rough man no yeah yeah i saw
that yeah i don't have much to laugh at
out there yeah they're still proud of
mesh
one of the characters in mash i didn't
even know this hodor told me kev told me
yeah he said one of the characters in
mash was from toledo in the show and he
like always talked about it so they're
holding on to this show from the [ __ ]
70s like my hotel had a army jeep in it
why the [ __ ] did you drive there i don't
understand the fight got canceled night
before because
nobody wants to go to ohio obviously uh
yeah
united was like we're not doing that
delta there was one delta flight was at
like 6 a.m out of philly
so either go to the airport at 3 30 in
the morning and then land whenever we
land or and risk that getting canceled
or just drive overnight and cafe is a
[ __ ] boss so he was just like i'll
join he brought his car up to new york
we ran at a minivan geez up fire oh
that's far so i love a minivan dog i
can't wait to buy it i know you love
this minivan [ __ ]